the psychological concept of envy what
is that
I keep putting myself in the mind of
Hitler I guess that that has nothing to
do it doesn't have to do with uh Jews or
Slavic people does it have to do with
specific amorphous
other
in his mind that he's Envy itself I
think it has all to do with him
all to do with him there's not a love of
the people with whom he Allied or even a
sense of the people who he persecuted
were worse than him it's all projections
out of what was going on inside of him
which was an intense sense of inadequacy
a rage at being someone he perceived as
lesser than that's the difference
between so we can define words in
different ways even within psychology
but let's say we take the definition
here of sort of jealousy as being sort
of benign right the idea that oh I might
see something that you have that I don't
and I might think I'd like that maybe
I'll work harder to get it right or
maybe I can't get it maybe it's that
you're younger than I am they say okay
you know okay you know you have that and
I don't I mean I have other things too
I'm okay anyway but I might want those
things but it's very benign the jealousy
I'd like to be younger I'd like to be
richer whatever it is that we people
think right
but it's just a thought and it's a
thought that can result in strivings or
acceptance right it's very very
different it's completely different than
Envy which is destructive it's the
thought of I see something that you have
that I don't have right and instead of
me working for it or accepting that I
don't have it what I'd like to do then
is bring you down
take you down to where I am and then
I'll feel better right because from the
perspective of Envy it is all relative
those jealousy a kind of is about
because he said completely different but
it's jealousy potentially like a gateway
drug to Envy like does it does it like
is it a slippery slope I think no I
think that jealousy is a natural just
part of the human phenomenon that we go
through life and we see like oh I'd like
to have I think it's probably part of
our incentives right if you know if if
I'm Farming and I have one row of crops
and I look over and I see that you're
working harder and you have two and I'd
like to have two that can make me work
harder to have two you don't think it's
slippery slope from one to the other to
at first you're like I'd like to work
harder but then you keep failing and the
weather sucks and you keep failing and
the other person becomes more successful
plus he's got a new hot wife now there's
a nice tractor uh does it feel this all
working and then you get this idea that
you know what I'm gonna steal all this
stuff I'm gonna murder him
and that you know don't you think that's
just like a leap no I actually think
it's the same phenomena no no because
but I think there are things that are in
us as humans right so so the things that
just by being human like we can for
example feel we can feel compassion
right we can feel interest right we can
feel jealousy in in that benign sense
like it's all part of just being human
if we if we start going from hey you
have more crops than I have and and you
know that seems like actually have a
better life in a lot of ways than I have
I'm gonna kill you that that's not that
is not a progression of something benign
right that is wait wait a minute but
there is a human leap of the same thing
isn't it is because you're drawing a
line stuff you're saying like this is
the this human stuff this regular life
it's benign
but it feels like this benign thing is
just a low magnitude thing
version of the thing that's not benign
because there's there's probably a gray
area where it stops being put like
jealousy you can have like healthy gel
so you can have a little bit slightly
unhealthy there's a that's I think
Jealous Guy this John Lennon song that I
love is just beautiful I mean there's
like this jealousy inside relationships
can make you feel like uh you know take
your minds in all kinds of silly
directions and it's crazy but like it
feels like that that's an extra neighbor
to like being really crazy and toxic and
all that kind of stuff inside
relationships and then that feels like a
next door neighbor it's like an
apartment building that feels like an
extra neighbor uh that eventually gets
to Hitler with the with envy and
resentment of entire population of
people you're right there's a causal
yeah there can be a causal chain right
like if I'm not feeling jealous maybe I
won't ever feel envious right so you can
see okay so it can kind of lead to it
can open gates to huh like how much do I
dislike that you have things that I
don't have right so yes in that sense
events but and I think this part I think
is so important that I think there is a
disjunction right it's there's an
asymptotic shift right from one thing to
another because if you speak in my
language mathematically yeah yeah yes
that that's it's a way to convey right
something that's entirely different
because if I start thinking
you know
I'm not going to try and make things
better right I'd like instead to harm
you that's that's qualitatively
different oh it's almost like you know
what it is it could be I don't know what
you think about this but
it's uh in which direction
your motivation is pointing
so if in the response to the feeling of
jealousy
your sort of
um the motivation says okay I understand
this feeling I want to do less of it
I think there's there must be a
threshold to which you actually want to
do more like it becomes a vicious
downward cycle so that's what Envy
becomes like the first feeling this idea
that I'm gonna kill the farmer
it turns into like more and more and
more and you can't sleep and you're
visualizing the farm and it becomes the
devil and like you have this very you
know it's it's a it's basically a thing
that builds into the negative Direction
versus returns to the stable Center yeah
now a person is cultivating evil yeah
right they're saying hey there can be
seeds of Evil in all of us let me take
that seed out dust it off plant it
nurture it right and then grow that seed
of evil which will affect all other
parts of the person's life right they
they won't behave the same towards
others in their in their life they'll
they'll they'll become different as they
nurture fantasies of evil as they begin
to create with side within inside of
themselves the the motivation and the
will right to enact evil right the
Hitler analogy would say look you take
someone who had a bad childhood right
who who like was not loved who who was
taught and told that he was less than
okay like that we know that happens I
mean that's why child abuse is so evil
right it's telling children the the
worst possible wrong lessons right
they're not good enough they'll always
be hurt you know they can't keep
themselves safe they don't deserve
safety right so then you take someone
who then nurtures that seed of evil
which is a choice and says well I can't
paint well enough and no one appreciates
me and I don't like how I look and I
don't fit in with the people I want to
fit in with and then and on and on and
on and on and on and there's a hatred of
self through that lens of misery of just
being repulsed by the self but that's
unacceptable to the self so oh it has to
be someone else's fault right it's not
my fault whose fault is it right and
then you see on mass the an action of
evil towards groups of people who who
somehow in this person's mind right are
responsible for his misery and there's
the justification of evil and then all
the you know whether it's this will be
better for the economy this will be good
this will be that like that's all lies
built to justify the evil those are
surface level narratives yes
and the Envy is the the deep down
mechanism that enables and that's the
endpoint that's being served what's
being served is destruction right which
is why it always brings more destruction
right I mean how many times do do
Wars that were started for purposes that
we would look and say like those were
evil purposes like how many times
does good come of that even we look at
the modern world what comes of it is
more evil is more destruction and
Hitler's outward destruction eventually
came Inward and you know you see
pictures of what Berlin looked like
after the second world war right it
wasn't just destruction perpetrated
outward as awful as that is it's it's
it's catchy right other people used to
worry if you you know before the during
the time the Manhattan Project right if
you start this Chain Reaction you know
we blow the whole world up right or will
it stop within this bomb or not and we
see okay the chain reaction of evil
hasn't yet blown the whole world up but
look at the look at how the catastrophe
spreads I think 50 to 60 million people
dead in the second world war which truly
was a World War what destruction was
spread around the globe and this is
something that can't be stopped once the
Chain Reaction starts like if Hitler was
successful like it would just keep going
if he had been I think if it's personal
psychological level I mean right because
we think from the perspective of
Destruction success would have needed
led to the need to conquer more then
there's factions and infighting and then
eventually you get the same mass
destruction right and and never does the
inaction of evil satisfy what the person
is initially seeking like people want to
feel better about themselves right we
like winicot who was uh uh a British uh
pediatrician who who wrote about
children and adults from a very deep
perspectives he wrote about the idea of
good enough right and then you can sort
of extrapolate that like we all want to
feel good enough like not just limp over
the line good enough but I want to feel
good enough that I'm a decent person in
the world and like what I do matters and
you know I can I can have an impact on
people and you know people can like me
and care about me it's there's a
Simplicity there that people want that
when people don't have and there's
certain other factors maybe they're
temperamental factors or historical
factors can lead to trying to soothe the
that deficit right through envy and and
I think it starts with with it starts
with that and it often starts in
childhood not always but it often starts
in childhood when when the child's brain
and psychology are so vulnerable and you
know you see Salient child abuse if you
if you look at what was Hitler's
background and what was Stalin's
background and I mean you could you
could look at almost anyone who's
perpetrated evil they're serial killers
or whatever it may be the the majority
not everyone but the majority had these
lessons in childhood that said you're
not good enough you can't keep yourself
safe no one cares about you and and in a
subset of people that's going to
generate envy and that you know that
that seed of evil then gets planted and
nurtured
as a fighter jet Brewers above us the
sound of a fighter Jetta boss it's been
good by an orchestra you forget you
quickly forget the comfort of being in a
peaceful place that's one thing I saw in
Ukraine
is um
hey you quickly get comfortable here the
whole trip back
I was thinking it's so damn good to be
in America the whole just a whole like
it's like a three day trip back it's so
good to be American
we might take that for granted
as a population but I do agree
so the destruction never alleviates the
envy
are all humans capable of envy
I believe the answer is yes if you think
do we all have the possibility of evil
in us I think the answer to that is yes
but we have
free will we have choice we we can
choose what we do with that which is why
just because someone is a sociopath you
know for example is it doesn't mean that
they're not responsible I mean our you
know our medical legal jurisprudence
right has
um has absolutely borne that out that
legally medically we think okay if we're
responsible presuming we're healthy
we're not unhealthy in other ways it
eliminates our ability to to be
circumspect but that we're responsible
for what we do and don't nurture inside
of us I mean there are plenty of things
we could decide to nurture anger and
hatred about you know I could think of
slights difficulties whether it's
something someone else has done to me or
I could blame fate or I could be mad at
God or the world we can all make those
choices and we're responsible for them
or if we're recognizing things in us
they're like oh I you know I too have
that in me but I don't want to nurture
that I don't want to Foster that or do I
choose to nurture and Foster that and I
think all ultimately in our subject of
Hitler as as evil if Hitler had kept
winning and winning right I think
ultimately he would have been the only
person on Earth
right and I really do believe that
ultimately everyone everything else
would be killed because it's such
destruction right destroy everything
right and probably when that didn't work
then there's the destruction of the self
right because
nothing
soothes
envy that is stoked by the sort of
flames of evil and what you see is more
and more anger and more and more
frustration which is why I really do
believe someone like that who who
nurtured evil in themselves that way
ultimately would would destroy they'd be
like him and one other person then he'd
kill the other person I think that's
really powerfully said but even just to
return to the jealousy versus Envy I
still think that it's the same Flame
and envy is just the bigger version of
it so I I think
I just in my own personal life
I've felt jealousy towards others like
you said like oh this person
has a I don't know a cooler thing drink
it whatever trinket I cared about and
usually it's when somebody's really
close to the the trinket You're Building
uh and I I early on like in my teens
I realized that
just just empirically speaking that
jealousy over a period of a week just
doesn't feel good
and it's not productive it doesn't help
me build a better trinket
um or it does if I turn it not into
jealousy
towards another person but into a love
for building a better trinket it's like
oh cool almost you know what like
proactively speaking uh and later in
life like people like Joe Rogan actually
have been really uh powerful in this for
me just as a fan of his
to celebrate other people so it's almost
as opposed to ignoring that other person
with a cool trinket is like celebrating
their awesomeness in my mind yeah like
just saying how awesome the humans are
able to do that and actually just how
awesome is that exact person and being
able to do that yeah and that somehow
made me more capable to build my own
trinket better yes and it feels good
also like it makes me feel happy and now
you're not jealous anymore you're not
jealous anymore right so that's why I
think jealousy is different right
because he's saying there's a week of
jealousy like I don't like this right I
don't like but if you take that in a way
that says wait a second actually this is
awesome this is fabulous and this person
did this that person's awesome right
then then what you're not raining on
anyone's parade right and in not doing
that even inside your own mind you you
gain a greater cognizance of your own
capability right well if he if he can do
that or she can do that what why can't I
too like I want to build I want to make
the better trinket too right yeah now
you're thinking creatively nowhere in
there
nowhere in there was the emergence of
evil I just disagree with that I think
there was a choice made where I I looked
at my if my life was darker more
difficult I think it has nothing to do
with the actual little flame of jealousy
I felt I think he has to do a lot more
with the other context if if I
if if my life were more difficult there
was more abuse there was more challenges
I think that decision I could have made
that decision a different direction yes
maybe I don't know
um yeah you you've written brilliantly
about trauma if there's a bit more
trauma as the background noise of my
decision making I'll be more likely to
uh not be able to pull away from the
gravitational field of that jealous
Scene It would build and build and build
a build so I think it's not to disagree
with the brilliant uh a person but like
I feel like that claim that flame has
the capacity to engulf the whole world I
guess the initial flame of jealousy the
little bit like especially the Younger
You Are
it's it's almost like a habit you get to
build in either direction because I've
early on built a habit of saying I'm
going to uh channel that jealousy uh
into productivity and into celebrating
other people in that jealousy disappears
that was like a little Discovery for me
I discovered that I get it that doesn't
come nobody tells that to you you kind
of discover that little thing I could
have easily not discovered it I could
have easily discovered
that it kind of feels good to to like
mess with that other person to like uh
think uh shitty thoughts think negative
thoughts do negative things to the other
person because that could also I I just
think the capacity in that initial
feeling is there and I think it's the
decision we make because like otherwise
I think it dissolves responsibility
like well surely I'm not Hitler
therefore this jealousy is normal no I
just feel like every jealous has the
capacity to turn into maybe not Hitler
but a toxicity that destroys in a small
way in your own little private life but
it could destroy I agree that
jealousy brings us
can bring us dangerously close to Envy I
mean maybe maybe let's see if if
um a heuristic we could agree on right
let's see so let's say okay if we look
at the terrain of the Mind as geography
right so if I'm feeling happy satisfied
probably like I'm pretty far from from
Envy land right right but but if I'm
feeling jealousy now I'm I'm I'm coming
kind of closer to that border right and
I still I think there's it's a big thing
to go over the border right that the
Border isn't a gray area right there's a
border to go over and I think that
you're I agree completely once certainly
about trauma that the more trauma there
is because then the more
misunderstandings there are about self
and feelings that I'm not good enough
and then that can be anger about why and
who might be oppressing me and you know
I hate myself and everyone else who
seems to be better like so the trauma
can drive us in these negative
directions but we're still crossing over
something right so so if you have the
trinket and I think that's awesome I
want that I want to work harder you know
what I could do though is I could sneak
in tonight when no one's around and I
could move something around no no way I
don't want to do that right but it's
like I came over the Border a little bit
and I thought maybe maybe that's a
better way but then I came back right
and I'm and you're we're responsible for
that right because it is a choice to say
I don't want to work hard I'm already
working how how hard I don't want to
make my trinket better I want to think
mine's the best one I could destroy
yours right and you know we're letting
our mind go over that border and do we
say right run that forward right let's
run that forward and put people around
us who feel the same way and start doing
it so we think less of ourselves and we
debase ourselves do we run headlong in
or do we come over that boundary and
that's maybe the capacity for evil in us
that we come over that boundary all of
us right at times but do we come over it
and then said no that that's not my
choice that's not my self-definition I'm
coming back but I'm trying to justify
maybe there's certain other sociological
forces that help us cross the border too
so in Nazi Germany we've been talking
about Hitler but then there's also the
the German people and so maybe when
there's a bit of a mass hysteria so all
these effects of like uh combination of
propaganda with the small jealousies and
resentments of the people that don't
cross the border uh uh together they can
with with great charismatic leaders that
sort of uh really fuel that fire that we
feel when we're a part of the crowd so
maybe those individual kind of
psychological barriers we have to take
that leap from jealousy to Envy those
can be made easier the the leap can be
catalyzed through this mess 100 100 I
think that to me is a massive point
we're talking about layers of emergence
right so if there's individual
Consciousness then there's culture right
and you know we're products of the soup
we swim in so to speak people would say
that when I was growing up right we're
products of the soup we swim in so if
the soup that we're swimming in is the
soup of hatred yeah right then it's
going to Foster all of those things so
then you think about just in a painting
with a very broad brush the culture
created in Germany prior to the second
world war and like what was the impact
of the reparations after the first world
war right of the the punishing
reparations impoverishment and you know
basic humiliation right that people were
feeling okay like that's there were a
whole bunch of decisions that impacted
that cultural perspective right then
there must have been aspects just like I
see in many ways parallels in in America
now of what are our standards for what
we're communicating to others right how
is the media deciding like what's real
and what's not real what's true what's
not true what's hatred that that is only
going to do evil versus what's hatred
that's okay because I might sell
something by by putting it out there I
mean that was we know that was going on
in Germany during the rise of the Nazis
and and I think there's a parallel to
you know do we value truth do can we
stand together and say no matter how
much I might disagree with you
politically right we can still
understand like that there's there's
right and there's wrong right there's
truth and there's lies right so so I
think those are just two examples of
determinants of culture and then the
culture is a determinant of you know is
someone like Hitler marginalizes like
that's a that's a crazy evil person oh
my goodness like whoa right or is that
someone who gains a greater following a
more adherence and then there starts to
be a momentum because why because what
do demagogues do I think they they have
a giant lasso and they harness the Envy
of of thousands upon thousands upon
thousands of people that's right you
feel worse about yourself too doesn't
matter what the reasons are maybe it's
your childhood maybe it's not maybe it's
job failings maybe it's professional
maybe it's personal it doesn't matter
like you have nv2 let's put it together
and do some destruction because that'll
make us feel better which is a lie